it's shallow ah time again oh you shut
the fuck up you like to this movie when
it came out I remember when we left I
mean that was one of the few times where
I'm like why you know today we see the
same film with this length is a bit of a
stretch I loved the first half couldn't
stand the second but you would still
like that person oh I did I thought
there was some great build-up in
suspense and I was hoping you would
build to something and then it never did
nothing talked right the camera angles
make no sense
oh yeah no no okay okay nobody really no
no no I know no you know no you shut
your whore mouth you say none of them
talk right and yet you came out of
unbreakable praising that freakin movie
like crazy and now let them talk right
in that movie I'm there's a whole
conversation between Bruce Willis and
Samuel Jackson and I swear to god it
takes 40 fuckin minutes when they could
have had it done in like two okay
there's two things with it because we're
it's not pauses I don't mean every one
of their words okay goes on for at least
30 seconds okay
come don't you dare mr. raggedy man why
you go to a graph right
Thunderdome was on the other day okay
it's are not to quote it isn't it um but
okay a couple things with that movie
first of all I think it's good to spite
itself in which you're absolutely right
about everything I think it's better
than signs oh yeah on second ah I think
it's something I realized is that that
what and the reads I think that film
works for the most part with that kind
of talking is that takes place after
this horrible event happens and during a
breakup and during a broken family that
makes a little bit more sense why they
would be talking like that why - Samuel
Jackson tug that way he's not going to
really not all day yes yes his body is
breaking up constantly
so that was the real comic book part of
the movie about how like you always need
a hero and a villain the two people in
the entire city you don't talk right
found each other which brings me to
number three I think everybody has a
film outside of Sixth Sense a Shyamalan
film where they're like you know even
though I know it has problems there's
something I still like about it for some
people at science for some into the
village and for some it's unbreakable
and from almost the first half of side
and valid in top right didn't matter
because you say it through embraceable
somehow completely fine and they all
talk exactly like they do inside it it
is harder to watch now knowing his
Trump's I will definitely say that uh
and I'm not going outside it's not there
but we should get the focus where it is
which is sides um another film that
again I love it when this happens cuz
this is another one of people like you
talk about sides there is a masterpiece
of incredible nest you can it changed my
life you can't do it and it's one of the
most even that or like a primal scream
and it is like love it too much so so
many people come up to me and say that's
like one of their favorites and the door
routine is one of their favorites and so
many good points are brought up that
they never saw before and they love it
or even if they still like the movie
they love the review the door where
Jesus came from us that one funny the
only funny scene was it scary movie 4 or
3 one of them this is the time when when
Newsweek was thrown out there I feel bad
next Spielberg and my favorite but my
favorite ever you look at an issue of
Newsweek just remember the words the
next Spielberg next to channelize and
then put your Newsweek back like anyone
reads magazines it's a bit of a wreck
ok but uh but the big thing where I said
ok
someone's going on with this dude now
like the themes going to his head or
something is when they were interviewing
him and he said ha edgy wrote ha no but
he said I can email if he said it exact
like that apart nobody but he said I can
take Pokemon and make it symbolic of the
Holocaust that's how good I am
he could it wouldn't be any good no
pathetic
I'm like I don't think this guy's fans
how this is supposed to work just
because you could you didn't something
you've you shot and I don't know for me
okay we talked about faith before and
we're both raised Roman Catholic and
stuff and you know there's definitely
shit that's like you know god damn it
you idiot you're you're ruining this
religion whatever and then there's
something up it's like hard elements
yeah and there's other people that can
take it and really analyze faith and
belief and the religion and stuff and
really take it to new levels that's like
wow that's passing that's intriguing and
this is one of those times where it's
written like a late high schooler who
thinks they have everything figured out
in terms of philosophy and religion and
everything and tries to make this
connection and there are a million
things that don't make sense about it so
I am totally fine with taking a story
about aliens and making it symbolic
about faith but first of all you gotta
make it symbolic you do just have hey
here's the fucking priest here's exactly
what I'm fucking saying we're literally
when you got enough right you've got to
make sense with it yes um why did you
kill the wife to have him leave the
faith just to come back to the faith
well nothing has changed I said you're
down one white well so God just killed
the wife well and not only that but let
his ways are mysterious yeah I'm serious
way I don't care about the ways the
final result is what I'm looking for
your final result makes no goddamn sense
then in my household I always knew when
I had won a religious argument when my
mom would say the Lord works in
mysterious ways cuz I'm like okay you've
run out of bay you've got nothing got it
like that was always like the final like
desperate straw to grasp like we're not
meant to understand them whatever but
the the problem not only is it that but
so the wife dies and she says swing away
so that he can hit the aliens at the end
but let's go back and think about this
had he just listened in the first place
and gone to the lake where there was
water what about the fucking Maury any
of it right so none of it adds up it
makes any sense
only thing I've discovered about the
whole faith argument in this film is
it's less of a testament to how
successful Shyamalan was at doing a
story about faith and how much people
just really want to have faith in show
that's it really comes in like I've
argued it to death and like I'll get
emails still occasionally from people
who want to talk about it and in the end
it almost always comes down that well
but the Lord works in mysterious ways
like it's all based on this assumption
I'm like yes and you're assuming that
God did this like or that God had a hand
in this how do we know it's not just
whatever well because he had faith in it
okay but that's in like in the end he's
investing some sort of faith in this and
we have no idea none of God had a play
in any of this which if you want to make
the argument that's the brilliant thing
about it you can I'm not sure that Shama
wants argument if you want might be on I
did this idea so much better a
little-known movie a call Slumdog
Millionaire uh uh and they did this
whole thing that's a little no movie no
that's it yeah uh but no but that's why
I'm saying is that they took kind of the
same idea that everything sarah has this
pathum isn't this way but they left it
just big enough and just open enough
that you can draw kind of whatever
conclusion you want from it maybe there
is some sort of plan on whether it's God
whether it's just you know the fate
whether it's this pattern that continues
or whatever you know something is going
on that is led you know to this turn of
events to you know all this terrible
stuff to something really positive and I
thought that film really dived into the
nasty uncomfortable stuff but when it
came back to you know that there is a
plan and there is hope and stuff like it
didn't feel it's a forced in the right
way it felt like hey we know this shit
can get really real but you know what
here's this local inch of hope that's
not just a shining light it's the little
things in your life that you never
thought would come back they're not the
quirks that obviously you're watching
and you're like well this is clearly
just a quirk force and is probably going
to come in later like the girl with the
water or whatever a lot of stories they
were saying in the past uh you know it
was done so much better it feels so
arbitrary like bad fairy tales or it's
like and then this happened because this
does this now like it's just it's just
nothing I get to have a baby in the
water well I mean lady in the water I
think is the final like death rattle of
shaman is literally it's like all of
these things that have been building and
building and building all of the
inconsistencies and his tropes like just
just explode in some like nuclear
fireball and like eat in the water it's
like it's like you pen to all of it up
and then you like just had a meltdown
like we're gonna do that one day I've
not got all the way throughout I'm
trying to smash up I tried to space out
the shyamalan there's a there's just so
much material uh but I gotta say I've
only gotten halfway through it because I
see my wife and I were just such a bad
movie like a really enjoyable bad movie
I saw the lies I heard this was bad we
will I got a little bored
cuz we were getting tired I just said
okay I acted bad I even said I got
stopped now cuz I'm doing a review of
this and I just want to save the
material kiss but uh no this is amazing
did you get the subtle metaphor about
criticism in that movie uh you know
again only halfway through it already I
got the fucking metaphor about criticism
there he's talking about people like us
okay outside science around science
oh so yeah yeah I'm I like I did okay
I'll say this and I liked the first half
of the movie because if I was gonna
build up to something you know good um
he is even in his crap films always good
at suspense
he has a hitch I think he's got a hitch
hacking through the scene with the door
were the aliens trapped behind the door
see the problem of those scenes is me
right there there was no payoff but they
all know yeah the build-up is always
great and the the problem is they don't
work when you think about it but in the
moment it's great you're there you're
terrified putting it on a farm with the
the signs appearing in his cornfield
with the the creatures scurrying about
it was terrifying it was done really
well and you don't know what they are
and you don't know what's going on when
it's revealed they're aliens at four
I like it it's only where it just it
starts to unravel in the end when he
tries to tie it all together and they're
allergic to water and so they invade a
planet that's two-thirds ocean and when
you know now the kids talk right now the
adults talk right but you know which was
the biggest distraction for me I was
actually even willing to buy see I
thought it was some icy to me that
didn't it bothered me way less than in
science because they're very troubled
family living in the middle of nowhere
like they all I just took it on I just
took it on thing that was going
somewhere that they were all weird so it
didn't bother me I'm just like alright
these are just weird farm folk wait
here's what's up like people are always
like how can Shah Milan say he was
influenced by Kubrick and Hitchcock and
all of it no everyday easily uh you know
but he again it is kind of like in
Battlefield Earth how that one director
had everything at an angle and you saw
the good directors have tilted angles
but he didn't know why it's the same
thing here Shyamalan knows there are
shots there's directors that use shots
that go on for very very long time
without a cut he knows there are good
directors that have very slow moving and
these long pauses and stuff and then one
of you a table and that's the first time
I've done to my mind there's a lot
easier he does it like yeah there is
nothing suspenseful is going on there
and if you're trying to create this
uncomfortable sense it's a it's not a
shoot I'm you shooting it like freaking
Dave and his other astronaut partner
talking in front of Hal or something
like it's supposed to be this
suspenseful scene but nothing's going
nothing's happening yeah and it's not
meant to be suspenseful so you're
supposed to be a nice are you doing it
uh you know and what I think was missing
is that both Kubrick and Hitchcock
created this environment that they
clearly had a handle line you can like
it or not like it I totally understand
but they clearly had a handle on it and
with this one he clearly doesn't he's
trying to mimic
because what he saw he does when he
wants to but you're right in that it's
just so much excess that it's sort of
it's like having all of these tools at
your disposal and instead of knowing the
right point to use him he takes the one
tool he knows really well how to build
suspense with the cinematography and
just uses it and everything I think so
after a while like it just starts and
that's part of the tedium and boredom of
his films is his cinematography is so
pretty but also at the exact same it's
like a paradox it's insanely gorgeous to
look at while being simultaneously
monotonous is fuck see how do we you
know I used to like looking at and I
used to like getting sucked into the
cassimy tog Rafi that they were doing
but I don't know looking back now I
think because it has been ruined so much
and done so much you know it's kind of
dull to look at now some of the
wide-angle shots are cool um well if I
had known it is interesting anymore it's
like it's like taking art classes all
your life and the only things you're
shown are da Vinci's yeah they could be
gorgeous stunning one of the greatest
geniuses ever but if that's you're gonna
get sick of it after that all you see
your entire life you know we're growing
up in school for 18 years you're gonna
get sick of it it's the same thing here
I think it's gorgeous I think it's
pretty look at I think he knows how to
frame a shot he knows how to do it right
he has a technical school but it's all
he does yeah like an after a while when
you just see it again and again and
again it just gets monotonous there's
just little variety in it I think when I
see something like Kubrick or Hitchcock
um and like I say you don't have to like
their style I mean I I told an but
whenever I see their stuff I don't get a
feeling of well this person is trying to
mimic this or create a style or be it
this is just how they want to do it cuz
they're kind of fucking nuts especially
with Kubrick I love Kubrick but he was
fucking insane see when I see Shyamalan
I see him I want my style style this is
my style this is but this is what I do
this is my style notice it notice it but
the funny
I don't even associated with Shambhala I
associated with Kubrick associated with
I associated with all of the other
directors that he's mimicking because
he's so desperate to create his own
style and use these techniques again and
again to prove something that I end up
not seeing his style I end up seeing all
the other styles he's using well you
know like in an unbreakable there's a
scene where he's being told that he's
the only survivor and in the fans know
one shot in the foreground you see the
other guy do one other survivor dying
and you see blood coming from the
bandage and it's such a it's beautifully
composed and it's brilliantly done
because you can see he's being told this
news and he's both sort of like being
reborn he's dying at the same time it's
just this uncomfortable feeling and it
really works it works in the story and
now I'm started wondering was that even
like in his mind when he's putting it
together was it just well this is kind
of cool this is my style this is my
thing there's a lot of things in the
foreground there's also the background
is a really really long shot it's like
that's starting to wonder was that even
there when he's putting it together and
I hate when I do that with a filmmaker
cuz you think there's any you can still
get that from it and that's what I get
from it but there is something almost
kind of heartbreaking way it's like you
know where you even kind of aware that
or thinking that when you point
something to give it actually worked
really well you know and maybe it's not
heartbreaking the more I think about
because it's still there and it still
works even if you don't like that movie
I mean that it's a good Apple say you
know like I still love the first half of
science you know the issue is it's just
kind of a the movie actually doesn't
even need a twist that's the problem
with it and this has been his problem
ever sends it like we need ever twist
they're allergic to water and then hold
twist fucks around with the whole
Slednecks from you know uh that devious
Christo um war the world obviously you
know they took it from something
innocuous that we take for granted a
simple yeah I mean it'd been done a
million times what is million but it
made much more sense and more the worlds
that ever does here know in that um
total logical sense in war the world I
mean they just they couldn't pretend and
nobody would have ottoman do you know I
mean water it's like the fucking plan
the planet is saying we will kill you
just with what we're comfort with and
that's part of this I think that's this
movie's biggest problem is it's science
fiction he may have been able to get
away with this if he did this like the
village without it's stupid twist
um with that one I actually figured out
by me both be right now you know I might
if I said right I find what the twist is
and I already guessed it I was like wait
is it this video as it we got it we do
be back to see the movie so but he may
have been better off budget because the
promise when you do science fiction you
have to have some science in it
and if your science is bullshit it's not
gonna work like you have to have some
basic oh yeah just like a rebate and the
idea that they can't get through the
wooden door that they you know are
allergic to water but land on a planet
like this you know the very idea again
that it's AHA aliens what is their big
glad they want to harvest humans like
Jesus Christ can we get past that even
when Pacific Rim and independence they
were doing it I'm like God Bailey says
something else that can stand I see
here's the thing too it's clearly trying
to create a suspense I love I'm a Grimm
- oh yeah no I like to see the Grimm's
amazing there was the only thing that
bugged me as I'm at the Independence Day
plot again I'm like that was Aaron Leo
not you know that's not the focus or you
know what draws you but in this case
it's the folk you know but but even here
it's like it's a it wasn't so realistic
it supposed to feel realistic like
you're in this house with these people
uh and it's constantly pulling you out
with all these weird it destroys it
destroys its own credibility and the
thing is I'm wondering if this film
wouldn't been much better if he set it
on a farm in late colonial times and
instead of aliens they're just sort of
some sort of like demon things in my
would be no no no in which that case at
least there are no you don't have to
worry about the science of it it's a
supernatural story basically if you want
to kill them with something simple like
water go ahead like there's no like you
don't have the same problems you do here
you know instead he does the village
which looks like a supernatural story
and then you know and then he does holds
the rug out from under you
because they don't sweet they does the
fantasy with lady in the water and that
clearly didn't work
oh I think like if you had done it like
that and remove the science fiction
aspect of it I think it would work a lot
but you had the same sub terrified
you're alone isolate a farm all the best
things that work worked without the
science involved why things well the
resource anti movie there is zero
science you may not entirely know
they're aliens except an event but it's
crop circles but I'll guess it might be
the reason Sixth Sense worked as one way
we're ghosts so well was because we
don't know how they work we know we've
heard stories and somebody's you know
usually we know someone or you yourself
come across something supernatural that
might be a ghost but we don't know how
they work so in something like The Sixth
Sense they can pop up whenever they want
you can see them whatever they want
because we don't know the rules but
that's taken off of what we've seen in
really big feet and this is their big
difference and this is why unbreakable
for me does not work and why I think
signs may bothered you to some degree on
way to give unbreakable the pass but
when it comes to the way they act
because that is the only thing in the
Shama on film I feel as stylistically is
their inability to act or at least have
normal human conversations that don't
sound like pre-programmed robots that
draw things out for like thirty minutes
um the sixth sense in the village take
place in the world where the super
naturally seems to exist and there's
this aura of death everywhere and then
the well I mean in the case of The Sixth
Sense we know why bunch of dead people
talking to each other um so that funeral
home aspect that's whenever I described
shamans acting style of his actors I
would say it's Funeral Home Agra it's
you're very quiet and you're very since
my reasons I like to unbreak 1/2 because
I felt that was kind of worn out from a
makes no sense and unbreakable zero like
no like Bruce Willis to some degree may
talk like that post in shock but if
everybody else though I don't get it but
in science it's the same issue to some
degree I give them a little bit of a
pass that they're on a farm and maybe
they're weird but
all stocks I um the village though in
the sixth sense I think of the only two
that they work somehow
because in this maybe Shyamalan secret
if you can ever figure this out for
fucking self is right supernatural
stories write stories of ghosts write
stories where it makes sense why they
would talk like they're in a funeral
home um and I think the village up until
it's stupid twist and the sixth sense
did that like he made that weird style
of directing he has actually worked to
his advantage
whereas I think all the other films he's
done it works to his disadvantage cuz
the village I'm just gonna be honest me
it's a pretty decent movie up until it
blows it sofa I've never seen the whole
thing I hear a lot of people say like
you know a tree it's out of his bad
field is kind of like the least bad but
it's still bad much like science for me
it's a film that it could have been
saved if you had somewhere to go with it
and the twist completely destroys it and
you're like like um you know that
there's two things I'll say that I guess
kind of three but they feed into each
other I do like in this film and one is
I you were talking about the build-up of
the suspense but they never have a good
payoff and I guess that leads to number
two which is the scene with the video
camera where it's like you know we have
seen you know I actually like Clancy I
know hey you know I love the build-up of
it I mean the build of those although
that's like one of the early like sort
of found footage scares in a sense like
oh my god like this feels the kids are
yelling is vanish out like real handheld
footage and yeah my gut I guess be it
just when you see the air and he looks
ridiculous
oh come but you're okay you're getting
too wrapped up into the the practical
effects service or the special effects
shot there yes it's not exactly the most
scary looking oh no but the build-up is
wonderful it's not only to build up his
reaction of flipping the fuck out
watching the TV that is the important
thing to take away from that scene I
don't give a fuck what the alien looks
like his acting in that scene was
amazing oh I can't pay attention yeah
Joaquin Phoenix reaction just flippin
like that sold the terror Betsy more
because you're right whenever pauses and
I look at the thing I'm
it's not that scary but his reaction
makes it scary that's what a good
haunted house film or monster movie or
something does it's about the terror in
the people and again that's why I think
the first half of this one was really
fucking solid I just wish it went
somewhere at the end but but I was
guessing to the ones now it ends like
The Wizard of Oz yeah the one bathroom
you know as much as we like to dump on
Gibson and everything ah
I actually thought for the most part he
did okay in this that the writing's not
very good but for what he had to work
with I thought he did okay and there's a
scene when I couldn't blame Gibson
anyway because I think it's firmly
established now no matter how good of an
actor you are Shyamalan will suck the
life out of you he literally is a shoe
impression we found someone that we find
someone that doesn't well yeah so
someone that gets through one of his
films in one piece like my hat's off to
them cuz like good job somehow made it
out alive but so I can't blame Gibson I
can't everybody else was actually good
yeah I was but I'm saying even if even
if you thought he was bad I couldn't
blame him like I I can't blame Mark
Wahlberg and the happening I it's like
who knows what someone's telling them is
good or not I would give anything to be
a fly like on the wall during the
happening here she'll Milan sake perfect
after every Mark Wahlberg take and just
hear what directors everyone was going
up what no what no we're not no it's
it's beautiful yeah oh but ya know
that's one of those things where it's
like I just love to know what what what
did you tell him cuz he's a good actor
I mean he's not greater than everything
but it's like he's pretty deep be same
with the Wachowskis many a great actor
goes into a chow ski film and somehow
ends up turning does not rob good
anymore a many bad goanna about the
exact same loot George Lucas another
grab those prequels is like there were
decent actors that went in there nobody
here some of them uh uh McGregor
an should the Brits all came out finding
my bris really when McGregor uh uh
the Emperor up like a snake eel
McDermott over the top and he's perfect
for that artist I think his performance
in Jedi is
the best but for pure clownish nests he
was great in the PIA no baby even when
he had to be like you know when he was
the senator like he was okay and then
when he had to turn when he got Sam's
the Sammy's like okay now you're like
look it's like you have to be really
scary now big baits are so somber
the point being so I give actors in
Shyamalan films of past I can't like wow
they're terrible
oh yeah I know because I've seen them
great I'm not gonna dislike Samuel Jack
it was women wishbone his sure Milan
mm-hmm he just does this name in
Shambhala yeah show him alive oh he
thinks this is somehow either help
people talk or it's how he wants them to
talk this home and it's weird yeah it
might be the Wachowski thing to where
they think if they talk like really did
really serious is the way don't listen
more because they've seen that in a lot
of movies I love older movies it has
worked in the past but they have
material to support you have my hands on
a script that supports sounding serious
because if you're going to go into your
super serious sounding voice then you
need to have a script that has something
better than you know let's throw some
water and well it's nice and body Mara
and I stand by there are actors uh who
just take that I'm gonna talk serious
the whole time and not be interesting
that somehow will make it interesting
and they do it way too much I think Emma
Cotter is one of them you know Russell
Crowe is one of them but but even with
them on them that's not the directors it
is their style yeah but but but even
with that like I always make the
argument with Russell Crowe in Master
and Commander uh I swear it's like his
twin brother or something cuz he is just
amazing in that he is so charming and so
charismatic and you are with him and you
will follow him and when he has to have
the really serious moment it's earned it
is completely earned and you're like wow
great acting you and III like Kevin
Costner and then people like William
Hurt in the right things if they're in
the right project where it supports that
style of acting they can get away with
it and I think it comes off really good
so I I agree with you not every project
sometimes you watch a Kevin Kotzur
performance like oh my god would it kill
you to have an emotion but but um but
yeah so that's our that's our take on
signs on yeah
the movie enjoy it I I look a little
deeper into faith though that is like
the one thing like if it did sway you
okay and even whatever it's good to have
faith but uh look deeper into it there
there is so much more interesting
complicated and even more simplistic
stuff that's I think it's just amazing
and I don't think this bill Mills out of
represented honestly um but but if it
really did something for you and it said
you in a certain direction fair enough
alright then you know and I will say
this most people who say that it's like
camels like a starting point for me or
reconnect or anything I'm like that's
great but they the interesting thing is
it's a starting point yes um I I'm not
sure I would consider this the grand
thesis on faith like this yeah um so uh
yeah I like the first half of the movie
a lot I just felt the ending and stuff
was a letdown and I much like and I give
them breakable this there's a good movie
trying to come out somewhere and I give
signs that too and even the village like
with all those post Sixth Sense projects
outside of lady in the water and with
them after that
with those three afterwards there's a
good movie trying to get out yeah
there's what I yeah tell ya I mean we
always say what a phenomenal concept the
goal what a great oh my god damn it it's
like you've got a head something I need
just fucking phenomenal here yet to
throw in the devil and I know he just
wrote that but his fingerprints are
clearly all over it oh no even the way
it's shot yeah his finger like maybe he
produced it as well because I whenever I
look at that I'm like this looks like a
Shamu and movie definitely raised like a
Shaolin way but yeah no II agree there's
always like there's always good concepts
there and even with lady in the water
why it sound like we're gonna try and
tell you a fairy tale it's like well
that sounds kind of charming actually
like a actual modern-day fairy tale that
takes place in modern times with our
buildings and everything but has the
fairy tale tale feel it's like I would
be very interested in that at age it
doesn't come through uh so yeah there's
always there's always the beginning even
up after Earth the idea of eradicating
fear like that you know doesn't make too
much sense but even for something that's
I think meant for young
like it's an interesting idea you can
have fun with it you can do interesting
stuff you they don't but you know you
could do something really interesting
with that maybe the Wachowski he's
hittin Shyamalan should team up I would
or would that be like hey to see the
Debbie I was happy like you're putting
the gatekeeper in the keymaster together
I would still pages ABC even though I
think that would be extraordinary can
you pageants or writing styles I need
just what happens when it's like at top
of a force meets an immovable object I
did it like I waited the traveler who
come on the form of a choice we all
wrote just get like the most boring
movie ever with so much talking so much
not happening and then just the most
crazy batching what the hell were you
thinking spurts and like a minimum one
batshit crazy performance probably two
now because they'll be working together
and I would just oh that's an incredible
um yeah get Mark Wahlberg and uh who can
we get from overshadow ski movie uh
who's been uh go no no you can leave it
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
no but yeah get those three together in
a shallow on wachowski movie and we
should do a Kickstarter for this just
like hey just just to get them two girls
okay you should come on you guys do some
together we love your stuff we're we're
not doing this just to see what an
unbelievable trainwreck it'll be I mean
we'll pay for it go I'm gonna kick start
I got a bad movie balls my great oh no
breakable matrix ascending we yeah the
six is breakable HS you know what let's
get writing get out it don't know
there's no writing we could do to make
it like this I don't know vici gets a
bad stuff going no no we just need to
like put together a treatment and then
email it to them and they'll be like
let's do it but I didn't come up with it
well say you came up with it let's do it
be excellent
ah we got a plan no we don't narrate
this ugh